how's it currently staying right now
Chris Brockman yeah who deserves the
most credit for the Patriots dynasty
Bill Belichick 67% Shawn O'Hara of the
NFL Network would you agree if you've
choice of Belichick Brady and Kraft
would you choose Belichick is the most
responsible about all out of all three
no I take Brady yeah is your player and
you know what it seems to be talent in
this league right brother well you roll
it up you can walk through it you can
watch show them on film this is how it's
supposed to happen
yeah but to go out and execute it the
way that Brady's done it I mean people
talk you know we talk all the time on on
and if I'm Network about hey this guy is
really accurate Brady is Joe Montana
accurate like and and what that is is he
doesn't miss like I mean the yards after
the catch every single throw from Brady
these guys are on the move I mean it's
it's so on the money that it's those
little details that that make him so
good yeah and I forget with whom I was
mentioning this yesterday
Brady's the best at not just throwing
people open but hitting them in stride
he's the best at throwing it in his spot
when somebody's not open to draw the
flag yeah I mean I've seen that so many
different times where you just he's like
I honestly think I've never asked him
but guys not open I'm definitely not
gonna get this picked off but I'll throw
it there and I think that's gonna be a
flag and then BOOM flag pops out of out
of the refs back pocket he's
unbelievable and he always it's always
at one of the biggest moments yeah you
know I also I mean okay the Miami game
comes to mind this year when when they
went down and they were over 11 on third
down but Brady doesn't have clunkers
like you know he never has like just a
bad day now but that was maybe one that
I could think of but in big games he's
not off you mean he may have a tough
series but even when were a hot boy like
last year's Super Bowl man Brady I mean
how's he gonna get out of this 28 to 3
you just he's got another level he
cranked it up another couple notches as
a coach yeah I mean I mean you could by
cranking up on the sidelines and you're
yelling
well that produces anything on the field
but when Brady cranks it up another
couple notches you know it shows well on
the NFL Network Willie McGinest is our
Brady whisperer you're our resident Elon
whisper he's stopping by here on Friday
is he coming he is alright um well he
was scheduled to you know we don't have
a contractual obligation but he'll
appear what do you think the Giants are
gonna do with that position with the
second overall selection in Eli and
Shermer now coming in what do you what
do you expect
well okay as you know there's a lot of
time before the draft so I'm sure a lot
of phone calls gonna be made and even
when you go into the draft and you say
hey here's our game plan with one phone
call at that number two spot everything
could change but I think when they
brought in Dave gentlemen and Gettleman
kind of looked at where are we at and
one of the things that Gettleman set has
said since he got hurt is my his number
one job as protective franchise well to
me you'll protect the franchise by going
on winning games with a veteran
quarterback has done it before in Eli so
I think that's kind of where he's headed
I think Eli's the starting quarterback
for the New York Giants in 2018 and I
think that they're gonna try to finally
fix what's going on in front of him well
how do you do that you're not doing that
with the second overall selection what
you're doing is you're getting either
say Kwan Berkeley or you're gonna get
your next franchise quarterback that you
think is the guy for the next 10 15
years that's what they're dealing number
two that that number to pick I mean
Berkeley to me that would be a slam dunk
that immediately helps your offense but
you still got to have somebody blocking
form so you know look I think that's
where the biggest question is do we
trade back do you get a couple more
pieces for the franchise and protect you
like look the Vikings did a good job
fixing their office line they were awful
a year ago and this past season they
brought in rumors they brought in riley
reef drafted elf line so you can you
could do it you don't have to go
overboard you could even you know just
sign a guy from the Cleveland Browns as
it was an undrafted free agent sometimes
that helps to have to go to the first
round sure I mean a couple minutes I
have left here with Shawn O'Hara here on
the Rich Eisen show what do you think
happens in this game Sunday sir what do
you think I wish I knew I mean we can
make a lot of money to just I don't know
what you mean when you say something
like you and me Shawn can make uh-huh I
think I think the Eagles are a better
team I think when you look at the talent
you know offensively you can go down
the offensive line I think the Eagles
olan is better
I think the collection of receivers for
Philly
you know the probably the real toss-up
is Gronk versus Earth's but then
defensively I think Philly their defense
is even better than Jacksonville's that
being silly okay
I can't bet against Brady so I I think
is really like the okay the Eagles are
better the Eagles have a better defense
than the team that totally confused them
for the first what would that be three
and a half quarters of the game yeah and
they have a coach that I think is maybe
a little bit more equipped to have a
quarterback relationship better than
what Marone and obviously Bordeaux's was
doing yeah but Brady's just so good that
that that flips the whole field flips
the whole script I mean we were just
talking about about how he is the
perfect weapon
you know he's Jeff Speakman yeah I mean
he can't really there's only one way to
stop him I mean yeah and we all know
that recipe you gotta hit them I think
the thing that's interesting to me I
think Jim Schwartz is gonna be more
aggressive when you look at Jacksonville
in the second half they played a lot
more zone let's Brady you're doing them
a favor though right I mean you're doing
a favor I think even if he completes a
pass if you can hit him it's worth it so
if you can bring some pressure and
safety pressure has kind of bothered
them on first and second down so that
would kind of be my answer and I think
coleus Campbell was a non-factor in that
game so you got to give credit the
Patriots tackles I mean Cameron Fleming
their third string right tackle played
in that game and and he played well and
Nate solders have an unbelievable year
great story for Nate Soler oh I'm sure
Brock knows all about it he's gonna be
an unrestricted free agent this
offseason so he's had a big year that's
gonna be a great match so maybe the
Giants go and do that and just before I
let you know in Kurt Warner's joining us
and in just a moment I dove I do have to
thank you you look I don't mind being
wrong on the show as you know I will
always raise my hand I was wrong we
reviewed my hot takes from the football
season I don't mind okay but I was
thinking of taking the Giants to win the
NFC in this building until I walked in
and I told you that remember that in the
preseason I do remember
legends lunch that you were busting my
chops no no no no it was it was in the
in the green in the green room what he
want to call our locker room I said I'm
thinking of taking the Giants here like
we had offensive line which offensive
line were talking about I'm like okay
that was then I got off the Giants
yeah everybody was picking him to win
the division yeah how crazy is that he
turns out pretty damn crazy based on
what we saw yeah thanks for coming on
brother I wanna see you I'll see you
later on the rest of this week check out
Shawn O'Hara
on the NFL Network all week long again
the NFL playbook Super Bowl 52 special 6
p.m. Eastern you can check them out on
Wednesday and then on Super Sunday part
of the eight and a half hour
extravaganza the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience